this morning cleanup and Recovery
efforts resume after tornadoes ripped
across the south at least nine people
are dead including seven in hard hit
Alabama the Twisters left a trail of
Destruction in the historic civil rights
community of Selma just before the start
of the Dr Martin Luther King Jr holiday
weekend the tornadoes ripped off roofs
crushed cars and uprooted trees and
utility poles this morning several
thousand customers are still without
electricity Omar via Franca has more
from Selma
we ran in this room right here Amanda
McLeod says it's a miracle she survived
a tornado that destroyed this Selma
Church daycare she's being called a hero
for how she and her fellow teachers
protected eight infants as the tornado
tore through the building I had the
seven week old here and I think she's
four or five months old here and I was
sitting down and when the power went out
I was just
like
you know I just shielded him the little
the little one the seven week old one
Selma Alabama took a direct hit a
20-mile path of Destruction cut through
its Historic downtown buildings
bulldozed and residents left stunned
it's bad down here like Louisiana it's
bad oh my gosh the storm was part of a
system that battered California this
week with more to come at least two
people were killed in Georgia including
a five-year-old boy after a tree fell on
his car
and near Montgomery Alabama cleanup
after a likely ef-3 tornado damaged or
destroyed roughly 40 homes Emergency
Management director Ernie Baggett says
it could have been worse the school
system kept all the kids in place rather
than putting them on the buses and
sending them home early do you think
that saved lives oh no doubt 40
tornadoes were reported now thousands of
people are still without power but we
have seen Crews from nearby States
working to fix that but it will take
weeks to clean this up for CBS Saturday
morning Omar villafranca Selma Alabama